mgm is working on not one but two pilots
for stargates the return and i know how
one of them starts
welcome to scitrek your sci-fi tv a
movie channel
[Music]
so if you're a regular site tracker
you'll know that i've been telling you
for a couple of months now the mgm don't
just have one pilot they're working on
the one that was written by brad wright
that we've been known about for a while
but actually two they've actually been
preparing storyboards for both of these
pilots and concept art now obviously we
know about brad rights he's told us
about it repeatedly times on his podcast
and we've known about it for a couple of
years now but this second pilot is a bit
of a mystery
we don't really know who wrote it we
don't know where it came from it seemed
to just appear sometime around january
in february last year and mgm started
kicking around the office now i have
heard rumors that this was actually
potentially written by dean devlin and
actually dean devlin talked in a gateway
podcast um a little over two years ago
about how he was potentially going to
produce a script for mgm and this was
going to be something that rivaled the
brad wright script so
potentially this is that i'm not sure
about this though because um obviously
dean devlin has now got a big other
project with a sci-fi network but if mgm
have this script and it's maybe
something that they'd like brad wright
to work on there is a possibility this
is that script that being devlin script
so why would they be working on two
projects there's a quick recap here
basically brad wright's project is not
massively popular with amazon they don't
think it's got a big enough scope to it
they don't think it's adventurous enough
so they have been kicking around the
idea of maybe going in a different
direction
now i actually have sources as i've said
before that work in and around mgm
they've been telling me this about
amazon's intentions but they've also
been telling me that amazon seemed to
still want to work with brad they don't
want to annoy the fans by kicking the
beloved showrunner out and going in a
completely new direction they want to
still honor the original series so
perhaps this plan of a second script is
just something that they'd want brad
right to consider and maybe work on
i actually am hoping that their idea is
that they're basically going to create a
hybrid of both pilots and that's what
we're eventually going to see on our
screens
but as i said at the start i actually
know what happens in the first five
minutes or so this mysterious new script
and i am going to tell you
so a big warning here this is
potentially spoilers because this
actually might be the episode they end
up making
so if you don't want to know how the
beginnings of this new series might go
and you want to wait until it's on your
tv screens in front of you then please
turn off now don't watch anymore
but if you are interested i can promise
you this is just a bit of a tease
because i don't want to ruin it for you
and actually to be fair i don't want to
ruin it for myself so even though i was
offered a bit more information from my
source mgm i declined it this is enough
for me so what do we know okay
i'm going to run through the first five
minutes or so here for you and it does
give us really a nice few little teaser
bits and we'll we'll talk about it as we
go so initially
it opens on an image of the gate and
that image opens up to a much larger
structure than the gate is currently in
so we're outside of cheyenne mountain
straight away in the images in the
concept art that my
friend mgm has seen it's described as a
very large glass and steel structure it
looks like they're it's designed for
large numbers of people to potentially
walk in and after the stargate so again
this hints at that the stargate is
potentially an open secret now we're
moving large numbers of people through
the gate nowadays and maybe the whole
world knows about it so there is a big
panning shot we see the whole structure
and then it comes back to the gate
now the gate lights up or has some sort
of static electricity or something on
the images i've seen it looks like and
lightning dancing around and then a
being appears now it seems that the gate
doesn't open we don't see the big flash
of the event horizon we don't see all
the lights light up we don't see the
spinning
it's just this energy and then a being
appears now the person is dressed
reasonably normally he doesn't look like
anything out of the ordinary from the
again the concept art i've seen but
alarms immediately go off and soldiers
running there's also talk about some
sort of automated defense system being
activated as soon as the soldier's
running the being puts his hands up and
surrenders and asks for daniel jackson
now that's really important because
basically it means michael shanks is
coming back now we know from interviews
with brad wright that brad wright has
already basically asked him to come back
and hope that he would maybe even direct
but this kind of confirms that
regardless of which script from which
pilot we get to see in the end mgm are
considering or thinking very strongly
about michael shanks returning either
way so then in the next scene daniel
jackson walks in he speaks to a soldier
they talk about how there's no energy
readings he talks about how the gate
didn't activate and that they don't know
how he got into the building they talk
about alright defenses and and there
doesn't seem to be any energy field
coming off him daniel though then he is
a woman's voice in his head a woman's
voice that he seems to recognize please
get in the comments and tell me who you
think that female voice might be i think
i've got a pretty good idea but the last
time we saw her she was in a bit of a
battle to the death with anubis but
maybe she's come back but anyway the
voice tells him be worried it's a
warning
and she says don't trust him the being
smiles and basically says hello to
daniel
n scene the opening credits roll now i'm
kind of hoping it's
you know like the proper sg1 music but
let's see what happens when it comes
back to being this person um he's drawn
as a male in the um
in the concept art apparently and the um
storyboarding but and that's not really
100 clearing hey they could go either
way with that when they come to casting
but they're sat in basically an
interrogation room
over each other from a metal guest
daniel's at one side and the being on
the other daniel's asking him where did
you come from how did you get here just
sort of like normal questions like that
the whole time daniel this voice is
going in his head it's telling him don't
trust him don't believe a word he says
danger danger danger daniel jackson
danger daniel jackson and that's
something
daniel apparently says to the being
general carter tells me that there is no
energy signature there was no beaming
technology
so how did you get into the building
again confirming that they're at least
considering bringing samantha carter
back into the series
the being doesn't really answer any of
these questions he just keeps smiling
and being very vague the voice continues
in daniel jackson's head but then at one
point the voice in daniel's head says
why is he here
the being then answers
and he says very simply i am here to
regain our rightful place
that is as far as i wanted to go and i
don't know anything else that's happened
i love how daniel can hear the voice in
his head the warning and then i love how
the being this mysterious figure answers
the question now in my last video i did
talk about how there are plans for the
anunnaki to be the main villain in this
series and i talked about how maybe the
anunnaki could be actually of an
ascended being now the anunnaki you have
to go back and watch the video of course
um i'll have a link in the description
they're actually part of an ancient
aliens theory they're sometimes
described as the first gods now if this
being is a member of the anunnaki
perhaps he was an ascended being perhaps
the reason why he can hear daniel
jackson's voice warnings in his head is
because that is an ancient whispering to
him and that this animaki this new
villain can actually hear the voice as
well now if that's true that's really
exciting because this villain would
actually be
potentially some sort of ascended being
and if they are back to regain what they
once had
well according to the story of the
anunnaki what they once had was complete
command over the human species we were
literally their slaves
so what do you think do you think that
this opening sequence of a new series is
potentially exciting is it something
that you'd want to see can you see where
they could go with this storyline or do
you just want to see brad wright's
version and you're not interested in any
of this competition between two pilots
please let me know or actually are you
with me
are you thinking that i'm not overly
excited by what i'm hearing about brad
wright's basically stargate academy
series and i would like him to think a
lot bigger like amazon apparently
telling them to do and that maybe this
second script isn't something they ever
going to produce but if they want to
maybe create a hybrid between what brad
wright is thinking and this other idea
to create something that's really
exciting and a much bigger scope than
brad wright was originally thinking
get into the comments tell me which one
of those three options you would
actually prefer
and if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe hit that bell
notification hit all the buttony things
and you can become a fully fledged site
tracker and support the channel please
hit the join button
as always guys please stay safe i'll see
you next time
you